the gyro can experience there's
everybody else then there's John Jones
it's another level he knows when you're
tired too he you see him when he senses
like any any time were you trying to
catch a break
he senses it and he starts ramping it up
and moving towards you and kicking your
legs so you see it smells blood he
smells blood he's a [ __ ] straight up
killer man he just knows there's a lot
of aspects to his game that are very
interesting but he just knows how to
feel where a guy is he knows the
distance in terms of like knowing how to
feel where a guy is in terms of how far
away the guy is from him because he's
the best ever at utilizing his long
reach but he also knows where the guy is
psychologically you know he knows when
guys are physically tired know who's he
fighting next he's gonna fight Thiago
Santos I don't know too much about how
my god that guy he throws brags more of
a striker the register oh yeah a way
more way more well he's got a giant
hammer tattooed on his chest he knocks
people in another dimension he's a beast
man
legit beast which is that um that's uh
it's not August it's not August in LA I
think that's the Anaheim card I think am
I making that up it's great [ __ ] fight
though great fight for as long as it
lasts who knows you know that guy he can
knock anybody out and she swings wild
but John should be a heavy favorite
going into the fight
John fights on the July card oh it is a
July card oh my god that's right deep
Bay and that's right that's where you're
confused
Anaheim steep and DC